People magazine is reporting that Justin
Bieber is being treated for depression
now it was back in 2017 that Justin
canceled some of his tour dates to deal
with it in an interview with Vogue
magazine that came out a couple of weeks
ago Justin also said I got really
depressed on tour I haven't talked about
this and I'm still processing so much
stuff that I haven't talked about I was
lonely I needed some time Justin also
said that his mom struggles with
depression and his dad has anger issues
he's almost feels mad at them they
passed it down to him he says when it
comes to music even thinking about
recording stresses him out I've been
successful since I was 13 so I didn't
really have a chance to find who I was
apart from what it did I just needed
some time to evaluate myself Who I am
what I want out of my life my
relationships who I want to be stuff
that when you're so immersed in the
music business you kind of lose sight of
yeah like one I'm support week we knew
he was going through some issues but I
thought him taking a break from music
was going to help him a lot I mean he
really has been in the public eye for
quite a while now I mean they just did
that vogue interview but I mean we're
not seeing Justin around for problems in
the last year so I'm surprised that you
know it's still you know he's still
struggling with it I mean just goes to
show you that no matter how successful
you are how rich you are you still be
depressed we've seen it before
yeah you know we've seen this we've seen
it before when somebody gets that famous
that rich that young you we've seen all
the outcomes and this is one that we've
seen before we've seen the absolute
destruction side and then we've seen
somebody who goes through Halladay young
age and comes out where now when you
look at them it's hard to believe what
they went through you look at Drew
Barrymore drew Barrymore was a drug
addict when she was like 10 you know and
so you look at somebody like Justin
Bieber it's not a normal thing like
people aren't you you can't expect
somebody to handle the life that he was
put into and I know he wanted and you
want to be a pop star and you want to
tour the world but when you just hear
these stories over the last look at the
last 30 years of what it can do to a
young rich kid and it's it's not good
and if this is the case if this is what
needs to happen take all the time take
all them don't even don't come back then
no and just work on it yeah Barbara says
I think judging from his actions is a
very troubled guy because he was
it was awful Jeremiah's gentle right
choice to get some help